when you think about what you compliment
your kids on what you encourage them for
what you celebrate is it stuff that's up
to them or not up to them right if you
go you're so handsome you are
complimenting something that's not
really up to them and if they don't feel
handsome then they're not going to feel
valuable I think about the other side
which is if like you're getting
reinforced that your handsome or
beautiful your whole life are you then
prone in your late 30s early 40s to
start having a real issue as your body
and your life changes and are you the
ones like that's a really tough thing to
have your validation framed on what's
beautiful all the Stokes would say is is
your kid making beautiful
they are about without you who they have
around them yeah so complimenting and
encouraging them and noticing the things
that are up to them that they're putting
in the work on that's fantastic right
are they getting better did they try
their best did you see them really
putting themselves out there that's
different than did they win did they get
the award whatever I try to focus on
things that are in my kids control